- Can you wear unhealthy clothes?
That's one of the questions you left
on a recent video of mine.
I'm answering that and so many more
from my comment section right now.
Huge thanks to Butcher Box
for sponsoring this video.
Stay tuned to see how
you can get a free turkey
with your first box.
Pee. Woo.
How can I prevent my nipples
from chafing on my shirt when I run?
You know what's funny?
I've never in my life
had this be a problem.
Maybe I'm not running enough,
but I feel like with
boxing on a given week,
I'm running 20 miles a week.
I feel like I should
have experienced this.
I don't.
Maybe I have chafe-less nipples.
If you are truly having an issue,
I've heard bandaids do
a good trick on this.
There's also like some antistatic spray
you could put on your body.
I've never had a patient with this.
I've never had it.
It's interesting that so
many people do talk about it.
Is it bad to wear Converse Chuck Taylor's
when I do squats at the gym?
So many lifters say they're
great shoes for lifting,
but when they aren't sold
in sports shoe stores.
Well correct me if I'm wrong,
these shoes were initially
a basketball shoe like back in the day.
I do think they're great
because they're supportive for lifting
and they also have like very flat sole.
I do think there are more
sports specific shoes
that you can use to lift,
but I've worn them before and
I've had good success lifting.
Is it bad to fall asleep
listening to something?
Only when it's your significant
other, they might get upset.
But if you're using like a
white noise machine, it's great.
What I don't like falling
asleep too is music.
Music that changes in intensity
and TV shows or movies.
Why? Because if your brain
is getting a steady stream
of information of sound,
it's gonna do fine and you'll
be able to fall asleep.
But if you're starting to get low sound
with a big explosion
that's gonna wake you up.
Have something that's on
faintly in the background
as white noise, great.
Anything else? Not a big fan.
My cat refuses to use the litter box.
Can you help?
You want me to have a
one-on-one talk with your kitty.
I have no idea.
Never had a cat.
Don't even know really how you teach a cat
to use a litter box.
If you wanna let me know in the comments,
I'll improve my cat knowledge.
Why does skin grow back from a minor cut,
but a limb won't grow
back if it's cut off?
Why does some body parts
grow back and some don't?
It really depends on the
initial type of stem cell
in a given area.
Bone heals and grows back,
skin heals and grows back,
nails heal and grow back as
long as you're not damaging
that base layer there.
But full regeneration of
most things don't happen.
Even for a liver to
regenerate part of it itself,
it needs to be there.
Like some of it needs to be there.
Yo doc, I keep seeing these ads
for posture correctors on my IG.
Do these really work? Should I get one?
I need to see the evidence on them
in like a rigorous trial to see
what it means when they say they work.
If that doesn't lead to decreased pain and
improvement in range of motion,
then the thing itself fails.
Now for me, I would much
rather get you in a place
where we strengthen your core muscles,
your back muscles, your stabilizers.
We get you in a healthy range of motion
where you don't need a posture corrector.
I think that's one of
those gimmicky tools,
at least for now, that
you probably don't need.
Why does it feel better to sleep
on the cool side of the pillow?
I think this has something to
do with your body temperature,
your core body temperature
dropping when you do go to sleep.
Like a lot of those memory foam mattresses
tend to gather and store heat
so much so that when
you're laying on one side
you just like feel that
heat bouncing back at you.
That can disrupt your sleep,
'cause your body tends to stay cool
in the early part of the night.
So that's why I think we like
the cool side of the pillow.
I like it mostly because
it's how I grew up.
I always hung out with the
cool pillows in school.
This is one of the hardest
questions but here goes.
Which is more important,
the heart or the brain?
Bro, the heart can't do
anything without the brain.
You know when they say
someone's all heart?
I say that's the brain being humble
and not taking credit where it's due.
Is it okay to never wear underwear?
I would recommend it just 'cause
like bodies have all sorts
of discharges and stuff
and it's gonna get on your clothes.
Like you don't wanna lift up your leg
and like flash everybody.
Genitals might be more
sensitive to the chafing
of like jeans and certain pants.
Protect your junk.
That's what I say.
Could you do a video about
if essential oils can actually help you?
That would be a very short video
because it would just be like this.
Essential oils sometimes smell good.
Check out this video.
Why do we feel the need to stretch
when we wake up in the morning?
Well, Lynn, because you've
been immobile for a while
and a lot of times you've had pressure
on certain parts of your body
for extended period of time.
So naturally it feels good to stretch
and get that blood going,
get those muscles warmed
up in order to face the day
and that's recommended.
Do you have any favorite Russian food
you remember from growing up?
Pelmani. My favorite food as a kid.
Borscht, close second favorite.
And Pelmani are essentially a
Russian raviolis, but so good.
Doc, settle this once and for all.
Is chess a sport?
It's competitive.
It burns a lot of calories.
Yeah, I think it's a sport.
If we're gonna call e-sports
a sport, chess is a sport.
God dang it.
I don't know why I got my football coach,
inner football coach outta me on that one.
Back to the questions in just a second,
but first I want to talk
to you about Butcher Box.
The holidays are coming up
and I couldn't be more excited
for all that delicious holiday food,
especially post boxing match.
Thanks to Butcher Box,
I'll be enjoying deliveries
of incredible meat and
fish right to my door.
Recently I've been enjoying
their Alaskan sockeye salmon
which is not only delicious
but packed full of nutrients.
It's seriously so good.
Butcher Box makes sure that
their high quality food is better for me,
the farmers, the animals'
welfare and our planet.
That's really important for me.
You can choose the delivery frequency too,
so you get exactly the foods
you and your family love
all in an eco-friendly
100% recyclable box.
They also make the order
process really easy.
Curate your own box with
whatever cuts you want
or you can save the time and
leave the curation up to them
for a fun surprise instead.
Here's the best part, sign up right now
and new members will receive
a free 12 to 14 pound turkey
plus $10 off their first box
when you use the promo code 10TURKEY.
Just in time for the holidays.
Not to mention shipping
is always free too.
I think it's a pretty good deal,
so visit the link in my
description to get started
with your first order
and enjoy some of that delicious
Turkey this holiday season.
All right, let's get back
to some more questions.
Hey Dr. Mike, is it true
that wearing the wrong shoes
or clothes can actually hurt your body?
Are there other things
I should avoid wearing
if I'm actually trying to stay healthy?
Yo, this is such a good question.
I've actually made videos
about this topic in the past.
Clothes do impact your health.
For example, women that wear high heels
for way too long periods
of time for many years
can actually develop some
deformities in their feet.
A bony deformity on the back of their heel
called a Haglund's deformity
also known as a pump bump
where it could actually
lead to Achilles tendonitis
or other types of bursitis.
You can develop bunions,
a neuroma inside your foot
and all these are painful
conditions that usually,
if you continue wearing
heels, will need surgery.
And know that heels don't
just impact your feet,
they impact everything above as well
'cause it changes your gait,
it changes your balance, your stride,
so you get knee pain, hip
pain, low back pain, et cetera.
But it's not limited to just heels,
it's stuff that you wear on your body too.
Like we athletes love
compression gear and,
yes, when you get all sweaty,
it doesn't matter if you're wearing cotton
or a polyester compression gear,
if you don't get out of it,
it's gonna be a problem for your skin.
But compression gear presents
a very unique problem
in that compression gear tends to
pull the oils from your skin into it.
So it kind of over time prevents your skin
from being able to breathe
with all that compression and
as a result you can form acne
on your skin, folliculitis,
even intertrigo into the
crevices within your body.
I recommend getting out of those clothes
as quickly as possible and
washing them very thoroughly
because if you ever had a
gym bag with some of that
polyester gear in, it stinks.
Because the type of
bacteria that eat the oils
from your skin that's
trapped inside that gear
release a really foul smell.
And it's different than cotton.
'Cause cotton doesn't absorb
the oil, it absorbs the water.
So if you leave cotton on for too long
there's like a chance fungal infections,
mildew if you don't let it dry,
but it just water so it
doesn't smell as bad.
It has a slightly different odor to it.
That being said, for women
who also wear shape wear,
that can also be problematic.
If you're putting a lot of
pressure on your abdomen,
you could actually worsen
symptoms of acid reflux
because you're putting
pressure on the abdomen
it can cause that acid to
come back into the esophagus.
Big problem.
For guys who love wearing neck ties.
I'm a tie guy, I love wearing ties,
but if you wear the tie too tight,
there's actually research that's been done
that shows wearing a tight tie
will decrease the amount
of brain blood flow.
Think about that.
If you're going to a meeting
and you wanna be sharp,
you need maximal blood flow.
So loosen up those ties, maybe
ease up on that shape wear,
because it can't present a true problem.
Oh! One that,
this is about to become
a whole video on clothes,
but if you wear very tight compression
like shorts or shapewear
on the bottom of your body,
you can develop a condition
called meralgia paraesthetica.
You could put so much
pressure on the nerve
that gives sensation
to your anterior thighs
where you feel like
numbness and tingling and
burning in the thighs just
from wearing that compression
and cutting off putting
pressure on that nerve.
God clothes, health, so
interrelated, who knew?
Maybe I'll do a whole video on that.
Mental and physical
effect of your clothes.
Can you explain what causes kidney stones?
I've passed over 50 in a year
and because of the pandemic,
my hospital won't see me,
so I'm left to just take
pain relief and move on.
50 kidney stones in one year is telling me
that something is going on in your body
that is outside of your control
that needs urgently to be addressed.
And you need to address
it with a urologist
to find out what condition you
have that's predisposing you
to so many stones being formed.
Because my suspicion is if
you were simply an individual
who ate a specific diet and
was dehydrated very often,
you would not form that many stones.
So to me it tells me that there might be a
metabolic condition, kidney condition,
even an anatomical condition
where urine flow is not passing
in the way that it's
normally supposed to occur
throughout your urinary system and
as a result that's causing stones to form.
Is it safe to go in a hot tub every day?
I mean like I don't see the harm in it
as long as that hot tub is maintained and
you don't have like a
rash or any other illness,
just dry off after and
don't stay for too long and
don't overheat.
Hot tubs can be problematic
if you have like a heart condition
because they get you warmed
up and when you get warmed up,
your body has to kick your
heart into higher gear
to beat faster to cool off.
Also, there is something
known as hot tub folliculitis
where you can get an infection
of your hair follicle
from a bacteria known as pseudomonas.
Looks painful, feels painful sometimes.
Have you ever been told off by a nurse
for doing something dumb?
Absolutely.
Maybe not so much recently,
but definitely in my training days
I made mistakes all the time.
In New York City when I was working
at a level one trauma center.
If you mess up, they'll
shove you out of the way and
start doing it themselves.
Like when I was first learning
how to do blood draws,
I wasn't that great at them
and I had to learn from
people who were better.
Most of the time they were nurses.
Why does swaying a baby put it to sleep?
It probably has something to do with
the movements that it's experienced when
the mom was moving around
and it was in utero.
When you have swaying,
you also have a constant
signal to the brain.
When you have a constant
signal to the brain,
whether it's audio, movement,
that is relaxing to us.
Whether we're talking about white noise
or we're talking about swaying a baby,
I think all of that is pacifying
just from different variables.
Like one is from audio, one
is for movement, et cetera.
Yao Ming 2.0,
Dr. Mike, why does some
people have a dark neck
and how do you get rid of it?
What you might be asking
about is a condition called
Acanthosis nigricans which
is a darkening of your skin
that can happen with
certain medical conditions,
most notably diabetes mellitus
where you have poor control
of your blood sugar because
of a malfunction related to insulin.
That being said, it could
be something as simple as
you don't wear sunblock and
you're exposed to sunlight
on the back of your
neck and not the front.
So like it really is important that
you do a thorough history and physical
before you just go start ordering tests.
What are your thoughts
on medical professionals
using their place of work to
make a social media content?
Would you as a patient feel comfortable
visiting a doctor who
was on social media and
used a practice you were
visiting as their studio,
so to speak?
Well, it depends on how they're using it.
Are they using it respectfully to educate
without making anyone feel uncomfortable
and still respecting everyone's privacy?
If so, why not?
I would be excited to go there.
Because I know what that doctor
or that practice stands for.
I actually get kind of an
inside look on how they work
and it gives me insight
into their relationships
and if I know that they're
all close with the staff,
that kind of makes me feel at ease.
What are some alternatives to therapy?
It's not for everyone.
There has to be other options, right?
Well, first of all, there are
different types of therapy.
Family therapy, DBT, CBT,
but really the ultimate thing that decides
success in therapy is your
connection to your therapist.
There's all types of other
therapies, equine therapy,
animal therapy, music therapy
that can be used in specific situations,
but it's always important
to make that decision
with the help of a mental
health professional
or a medical doctor.
Should I wear gloves when I lift weights?
You can go in many
directions here, Bailey.
Some people for aesthetic reasons
will choose to wear gloves.
They wanna prevent calluses from forming.
I think the callus is beneficial
as long as it's a healthy callus,
meaning that it's not too
big, it's not overly dry.
Because what happens is if it gets
really big and overly dry,
it can totally rip off
and then you have no padding
at all for the weight.
So you need to be smart
and in some instances
maybe wear gloves or even
they have some of these grips
where you can just like put on a grip and
you don't have a full glove,
therefore you're not like
retaining all that moisture
on your whole hand, but
only on the palm or surface.
What's a nice gift to
give a doctor or nurses
or other hospital staff
after an extended stay?
I think the rule is
medically, ethically speaking,
it has to be under $30 or something.
That's the the guideline set
by a professional organizations.
Making a nice meal for
them, some cookies or
an inexpensive bottle of wine
if you know they like wine.
If you're my patient,
don't get me anything.
Just stay happy and healthy
and keep working on yourself.
Click here to check out my
reaction to the survival show
Naked and Afraid, a
lot of things go wrong.
And remember to sign
up for Butcher Box now
to get a free 12 to 14 pound
Turkey in your first box.
As always, stay happy and healthy.